are the Big Bang stars really ready to
say goodbye it's bittersweet seem very
sad to be saying goodbye to my family we
just it all happened so I'm trying to
process all of it we were there when we
found out together and we're there to
support each other that's all that's all
there is to it really that's why we've
survived for this long is because we
love each other we're a family and we
support each other
so that love and affection may be the
main reason why the Big Bang Theory's
ensemble cast has remained tight-lipped
the reason why TV's number one comedy is
ending still hasn't been confirmed
despite reports was the show's leading
man Jim Parsons who decided he was ready
to step away
back in March Jim was unclear on the
show's fate there's been no group
discussion I'm waiting for this
conversation I could start it I guess
but I haven't because that wasn't my
role but maybe it is now but co-star
Katie Cuomo was crystal clear rooting
for the show to go on I love being part
of the show and I think it'd be really
stupid to to to say no they cast however
has often stuck together during contract
negotiations in fact last year in a show
of Big Bang unity the five original cast
members led by Parsons decided to take a
pay cut in their salaries to raise the
salary of their co-stars melissa rauch
and Mayim Bialik who posted on her
website disappointment about the ending
of a series am I happy of course not
it's very sad I fear it's going to be
very hard to not cry every day meanwhile
Kunal Berg news to et that the sitcoms
bittersweet final episode will tape
Tuesday April the 30th 2019 this is
gonna be the greatest season the B never
ever gonna do actually our last taping
is on my birthday so it'll be an
interesting
congesting like
[Music]